大家好,下面给大家来介绍一下怎样选择使用模式。
当您第一次登入到软件之后的话,因为没有选择使用模式,这里会有一个弹框,让您选择一下使用模式。
第一次使用的话,您可能有点不太清楚,到底该选哪个。
但是这里是可以先取消,然后待会儿您可以后续再重新选择点这个地方就可以了。
这里有个图您可以先看一下,现在这两种模式下都是什么样子。
如果您的店铺是跟其他人的店铺是分销商的关系,比如您是下游的分销商,或者您是上游的分销商,您还要自己的下游分销商。
您管您的店铺,他们管他们的店铺,就各管各,但是您和他们之间又需要有一些数据上的同步,或者说是要复制商品,互相复制商品这种操作。
您就可以用这种分销商模式,它最主要的特点就是,各自用各自的店铺账号登陆到软件里面去做操作。
您不能用它的账号登陆,您也不能去操作它的账号,您只能用自己的账号登陆和操作自己的账号,这是它的特点。
另外这个店群模式的话,就是说,如果您有好几个店,比如说有一个组店,那其他有几个都是分店,那这些店的话全都给您管,您一个人管这么多店。
那这个时候的话,如果您使用这个软件,您每个店都登陆到软件里面去操作,就有点太麻烦。
所以的话,您把这些店全部设置成店群模式,放在一个店群里。
那之后的话,您只需要用这个组店来登陆到软件里去操作。
包括这些店群之间的这个商品的复制商同步,都是用这个组店这个号来登陆软件来操作的。
这个时候就很方便,您不再需要用分店一个月去登陆到软件里了。
您只要用这个组店来操作就可以了。
这种模式就电磁模式。
所以说,您看一下您的这个应用是哪种场景,您来决定自己用哪一种模式。
在这个页面上,您可以随时点上面这个,请选择使用模式这里来进行勾选,选择您的使用模式。
好了,谢谢大家,介绍就到这里。